I'd say the outset it's it's great news
of the UK economy is recovering it's
great news - unemployment is coming down
the misery index if you like the
addition of growth and inflation is is
unemployment and inflation is low all
those are good things my concern is that
the Western recovery in general
including the UK recovery is largely
built on debts post subprime we seem to
be addressing a problem of too much debt
with more debt also asset prices are
extremely stretched and overvalued
largely because we are in the middle of
the most expansion airy monetary policy
in the history of man it strikes me that
the the political narrative particularly
from Westminster is all about the
economy improving the feel-good factor I
don't want it to happen it doesn't bring
me any pleasure to write about it or say
it but I feel as an economist a
financial analyst somebody who follows
core politics closely but also as a you
know being an asset manager somebody who
who delves deep into financial issues
that there are an awful lot of people
out there who are actually extremely
worried and taking money off the table
even though they're not talking about it
it's very difficult to speak out and
ruin the party when everybody's making
money on the party and there's a whole
you know strata of people in the city
brokers and so on who want to keep
making hay and keep the rally going the
the Western stock exchanges have risen
hugely in the last two to three years
even though there's been very little in
the way of a convincing economic
recovery even though corporate profits
have been down even though you have a
great deal of geopolitical concern out
there nobody wants to think about the
fact that the Fed tapering will come to
an end and there'll be no additional QE
every month ostensibly from October
and the long-term valuations the
technicals a lot of Western stock
markets point to really quite serious
over valuation at this point and markets
are now essentially reacting according
to whatever the banks beyond a lien
fundamentals really its but the other
side of that as well as the simple bank
is now under monetary policy is
essentially also a function of market
expected market reaction so we saw last
year introducing the Fed and Bernanke
started talking about tapering the big
market reaction and they held taper
tantrum yeah but then we did a number of
months later they prepared the
groundwork they'd make sure that with
Ford go it's not pretty but at least
there was some sort of understanding
there was something happen and the
reaction when it actually did happen was
very very moderate very in fact even
positive so I think that central banks
are sufficiently aware that markets can
be very destabilizing so this time is
different right look if printing
virtually or otherwise huge amounts of
money led to sustainable wealth and
justifiably high asset prices then
Zimbabwe would be in in the g7 look of
course the political narrative the
narrative of the stock brokers and the
and the commentators who rely on their
City contacts because they're not
capable of independent thoughts must
maintain this narrative because so many
people's livings are tied up within it
it strikes me that stock markets have
been rigged now basically somebody has
to say it but thought of shooting me for
four or five years I've always
maintained having been extremely
skeptical about QE from the very
beginning and I must say the CPS was an
early convert to my position if you like
I've always maintained there was some
justification for emerging matures at
the very beginning no one wants to see a
systemic banking crisis if you've lived
in emerging markets and in some weird
wonderful places I have just now banking
crisis lead to social unrest lead to
lethal
it's linked to regime changes coos nasty
bass human behavior nobody wanted that
my point is that QE in this country was
billed as a fifty billion pound
operation it's been a six hundred twenty
five billion pound operation the the the
the numbers proportionately is just the
same in in the u.s. it was an emergency
measure that because it helps the
politicians to keep on spending and rig
the gilts market and because it helps
the banks to get a backdoor bail out and
try and rebuild their positions without
taking proper write downs and and being
accountable for their previously mad
investment decisions it's become a
lifestyle choices become crack cocaine
your professor Michael Dempster's very
convincing wasn't he and he says you
know the last crisis was caused by cheap
money and it's happening again via q
well you know I must take my hat off to
Michael Dempster at Cambridge an ad
Mattie these these standing these these
are extremely serious yeah
studious people from the most
prestigious organizations academic
organizations on the planet they are not
you know sitting in a bedsit day trading
and taking pulsed to try and get their
name namely papers and so many academics
so-called finance academics are captured
they are reliant on was it on the
financial services industry for their
funding directly or indirectly now or in
their future careers they hope but
increasingly independent academics and
these two are genuinely independent are
standing and talking and also with in
high-end financial circles a lot of
people are really really concerned and
it's it's the job of people who cross
these worlds to inject this this force
into the matrix I'm not saying there's
gonna be a crash in October when QE ends
all I'm saying is that an awful lot of
extremely sophisticated experienced
people are very worried that there might
be and that will completely change the
political narrative and that is also
something that will be of interest to
people investing you know their nest egg
their life savings